you know your personality creates your
personal reality that's it and your
personality is made with how you think
how you act and how you feel so if you
keep thinking the same way you keep
acting the same way you keep feeling the
same way everything stays the same in
your life because nothing changes in
your life until you change right so
turns out if you keep thinking the same
way making the same choices doing the
same things creating the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions or responding to your life in
the exact same way you keep doing that
your biology tends to get more rigid we
fire and wire the same service we
hardwire our brain and they it only
takes a small stimulation or small
fodder a response to someone or
something and like a sequence of
thoughts it just turns on automatically
need motivation what's your top ten with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
of my first business I struggle to stay
afloat I quit my business partner and
the thing that kept me going was
studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the courage to
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's learn from one of the
best Joe dispenza and my take on his top
10 rules of success enjoy
so your biology your neurochemistry your
your hormones your genes everything
stays the same because you're the same
so crisis and Trauma is always the thing
that gets a person to really start
looking at how do I really change right
so so we want to tell people let's not
wait for that let's let's learn and
change in a state of growth and
inspiration so
so if you keep doing those same things
over and over again the middle life
period we we become very very
programmable
so
in order for us to change we have to
become conscious of how we think we have
to become really aware of how we behave
what our habits are even how we speak
now this is a tough one we have to
really look at the emotions that we live
by every single day and and say wow this
this actually could be unworthiness this
could actually be guilt but if you're
too busy with your cell phone and your
social media and you're too busy with
your kids and running around and as well
your environment can distract you from
these feelings so
my interest is to get people to retreat
from their lives right just for
five seven days and and remove the
constant stimulation in their external
environment that reminds them of who
they think they are as a personality
to separate themselves from the people
they know and the places they go and the
things they do at the exact same time
and then fill their brain with knowledge
and information and then remind them
that they're actually creating their
life
so if your personality creates your
personal reality and that means that if
in order for you to change your personal
reality you got to change your
personality rule number two is think
abundantly how would an abundant person
think write it down dude and fire and
wire those thoughts in your brain and
install the hardware keep doing it with
attention and intention it becomes the
new voice in your head it becomes a
software program then say okay
how am I going to be in my life today
what would an abundant person how would
they behave and before you reach for
your cell phone start scrolling through
your social media close your eyes and
rehearse in your mind how that person
would walk how they would Breathe how
they would smile how they would greet
people how they would be on Zoom calls
how would they be in traffic how would
they be at dinner
and and the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing the ACT if you're
truly present
the brain does not know the difference
between the real life experience and
what you're imagining in fact just a
little bit of time you start to install
the neurological Hardware to look like
you already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it's primed
for the future keep doing it keep
rehearsing no different than playing an
instrument no different than learning
how to dance no different on learning
how to act or play a sport everybody's
always rehearsing right the rehearsal
process
changes the brain to look like you've
already done it you've already
experienced it now what's the essential
part of that the hardware is in place
now all you got to do is step into the
footprint keep doing it it becomes a
software program you start acting like
an abundant person everything changes
your energy changes your mood changes
the way you walk where you breathe your
posture changes you're out of the known
right you've got to condition the body
now emotionally into the future
can't open your eyes in the morning
until you are feeling worthy to receive
and if you can't feel worthy to receive
then if not now when if it takes you two
hours to get there ask me if it's worth
30 years
of running trying to get what you need
matter to matter okay so then the person
who wrestles with their lack they're out
of the bleachers
and they're on the playing field here's
what we learned here's what we learned
let's go back to beliefs now so remember
belief is just the thought you keep
thinking over and over again a belief is
something that you keep thinking enough
times that you hardwired in your brain
and it becomes an automatic program and
we have beliefs about all kinds of
things money relationships God whatever
it is it's all based on what we've been
told or our past experiences right
boundaries of those beliefs or our
emotions right so let's just say you got
betrayed or somebody abused you or your
father told you that money was bad and
there's never enough of it or whatever
that's a story okay but but somehow it
left an impression on you remember that
event very clearly and that's kind of
rooted in who you are right
okay so that emotion then is the
boundary of our belief Okay so
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being if you take a
thought and a feeling a thought and a
feeling of thought and a feeling of
thought and a feeling it's called an
attitude yes here's a good thoughts with
a series of Good Feelings you say I have
a good attitude today you have a series
of negative thoughts that are connected
to a series of negative feelings you see
have a bad attitude today so attitudes
are just shortened states of being good
attitude in the morning bad attitude in
the afternoon if you take an attitude
and attitude imagine you keep those up
any string attitudes together you create
what's called a belief and a belief is
just an extended state of being so if
you keep thinking the same thought you
keep hard wiring in the brain you keep
feeling the same feeling you keep
conditioning in your body the redundancy
of that cycle over and over again
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of that belief and all
beliefs
our subconscious states of being okay
take a belief a belief a belief and you
string them together you're from what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are right and
people are always feeling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
their research to prove this okay rule
number three is feel the experience how
many things
you could get done if you had an
infinite amount of time
and if a number of possibilities that's
the quantum now in the quantum there's
nothing structural there's nothing
material there's nothing physical
there's no form right so what is it made
of it's made of energy frequency
vibration
thought Consciousness information and
every thought in that realm has a
frequency so all possibilities already
exist you don't have to create the
possibility in fact all you have to do
is become aware that exists
the moment you do that you you're
changing the thought and you're
producing a different frequency now if
the person is astute enough to feel the
frequency of the thought in the quantum
and not wait for the experience to
happen but the thought of abundance
would produce the feeling of abundance
for most people in three-dimensional
reality the thought of abundance
produces the lack of not having it
that's why they're trying to create it
right but in the quantum you got to feel
it in order to experience it okay so as
you get closer and closer to that point
that source that Singularity pure love
the zero point field whatever you want
to call it the universal mind that the
Creator pure Consciousness as you get
closer and closer to it
the closer you get to it the more bliss
the more love the more the more
um ecstasy you feel uh then you're not
no longer creating from lack or
Separation The Closer you get to it in
the process of creation the shorter the
distance between the thought of what you
want and the experience of having it
between the cause and the effect from
one point of Consciousness then the
other point of Consciousness so then
people can create from the field instead
of from matter
if they have a coherent brain and a
coherent heart and they actually can
send the coherent signal out and feel
the emotion ahead of the experience then
those synchronicities and opportunities
that they're creating from fifth
dimensional reality requires doing less
somehow it's drawn to us or it comes to
us it comes in ways that we least expect
that surprises us like whoa where did
that come from and now what does that do
it proves to you that you're the creator
of your life that instead of the victim
of your life and what's a victim
you say to someone why are you feeling
this way what's wrong with you today and
they say I am this way because of that
person because of that circumstance what
they're really saying is that person or
circumstances actually controlling my
feelings and controlling my thoughts
well anything that's controlling my
feelings and my thoughts I'm victim to
right so yeah it makes sense then that
when things are good you feel good when
things are bad you feel bad right so so
when you start changing the way you
think and feeling it starts producing
outcomes in your life you're going to
believe you're more you're the creator
of your life and less of the victim of
your life and the hardest part about all
of this is just making the time to do it
rule number four is relax your heart
when people
first thing they have to do is they have
to overcome their survival States they
have to overcome their programs they're
going to be willing to sit with
themselves long enough to wonder what's
on the other side of I can't where it's
too hard or I want to give up or this
sucks what's on the other side of those
thoughts those are just program thoughts
what's on the other side of this emotion
called guilt or this emotion called
frustration what's on the other side of
it right so you get people to a certain
point and give them a little bit of help
but the key then is we've done we've
done studies on this
if you close your eyes and you place
your attention on your heart
turns out where you place your attention
is where you place your energy right so
if you can put your attention on your
heart and not your cell phone
and you can keep it on your heart and
and feel it and experience it and pay
attention to it by paying attention to
your heart you're actually giving it
your energy now your heart tends to feel
different emotions than other parts of
your body and what emotions it loves to
feel is love Compassion Care kindness
gratitude inspiration Freedom these are
elevated emotions
so if you could put your attention on
your heart we see from the technology
that we built in time and not a very
long amount of time just a few minutes
you'll start to see this very low
frequency of the heart start going up
which means the the energy that's
indigenous to the heart with the heart
uses only you're actually feeding it
it's it energy right so if you could do
that then and then you can slow your
breathing down when you slow your
breathing down you slow your brain wipes
down we've measure that thousands of
times so instead of this short breath or
this instead of this kind of shallow
breath
can only work on taking long slow
breaths through your heart inhale with
the intention of relaxing hold it with
the intention of relaxing while you hold
it exhale with the intention of relaxing
blow all the air out hold it for a few
seconds you're not going to die relax
again inhale again and just do a series
of three or four or five or six of these
depending on working with your body so
that it starts to feel safe again that's
what it is to slow your brain waves down
you slow your breathing down you slow
your breathing down you convert from the
sympathetic
to the parasympathetic and that's what
we see then all of a sudden we see the
person's parasympathetic nervous system
go up and sympathetic goes down what
does that mean
they're not moving out of stress okay
the body is moving into that state of
growth and repair now put your attention
on your heart now do something really
cool amplify that's the amplifier that's
the creative Center so what do you want
to feel like what emotion do you want to
feel when a future experience happens
whatever that is feel the Gratitude feel
the joy feel the freedom and breathe and
feel and feel and breathe and keep
relaxing into your heart keeping your
attention nowhere else out of the
millions of things you can put your
attention on that's your Target and you
work with your body and your breathing
you're feeling as you start relaxing
into your heart you keep working on
relaxing into your heart and you feel it
you feel that emotion there'll come a
moment where that energy will naturally
start moving up to the brain and when
that happens
the survival centers shut down brain
moves into Alpha you see more in
pictures and images that you could take
it's like a taking a sheet of paper a
sheet on a bed and going like this the
heart sins is propagating wave right
into the brain just follows boom right
after the stroke volume and it's telling
the brain to be creative to dream to be
you know to be unlimited so the more you
do that here's the key
the more you do it the more it becomes a
skill now
when a person has a panic attack right
what they do is they mismanage their
attention they they picture the worst
scenario that could possibly take place
and then they say no what if this
happens what if this happened what if
this episode they're making it actually
10 times worse because if you prepare
for the worst there's always better
chances of survival the problem is
they're combining that image in their
mind and they're actually living the
experience emotionally
and so they're taking that thought and
that feeling that image and that emotion
that stimulus and response and they're
conditioning the body subconsciously to
become the mind of fear
after a certain point when the body's
that out of balance it will have a panic
attack try as you may to control it with
your conscious mind can you programmed
it subconsciously then it gets worse
because after that one you can't
anticipate when the next one's going to
happen so you start getting ready for
the next one and that's what exactly
starts the cycle okay so what we
discovered that the more you relax into
your heart and feel these elevated
emotions it's exactly like a panic
attack only it's a love attack also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is always be
grateful the emotional signature of
gratitude means something's happening to
you
something has happened to you you're
receiving something or you just receive
something so your body then when you're
feeling gratitude is in the perfect
state of receiving so then that means
then
you'll accept believe and surrender to
the thoughts equal to the emotional
state of gratitude if you're living in
resentment you're living in fear you're
living in in patience you could say I'm
healthy I'm healthy I'm healthy I'm
wealthy I'm wealthy I'm with all you
want and that thought's going to stop
right at the brain stem and never make
its way to the body because the body is
not failure because why because you're
feeling resentment and that thought
isn't that thought
is not consistent with the emotion of
resentment resentment has a different
set of thoughts right in other words
once you start opening your heart
it begins to move into coherence it
begins to produce a measurable magnetic
field up to three meters wide now that's
frequency that's energy and all that
energy that frequency carries
information carries an intent so then
when you're feeling gratitude and your
heart is open you're broadcasting energy
into the field the frequency the
frequency you lay the intent of the
thought of your health or your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering you
can't the suffering does not carry that
energy does not carry the thought of
your wealth it carries a different set
of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated right
and you better know how to self-regulate
and you have to know the moment you
disconnect from the energy of your
future because of some circumstance in
your life and you lose that feeling if
you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change the the
frustration from some experience in your
life back to the energy of your future
now
that requires Great awareness and great
effort but if you have a commune of
people that are practicing this on a
daily basis and they're connected to
their future because that's where their
their mind is
um they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past rule
number six is change your story let's
just say that lack is ingrained in there
you got the story you lived on the
streets you lost everything you got
betrayed your business partner took
everything took your wife took you got
the story in the half okay okay you
gotta start telling the new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
the future right okay so in order for us
to change a belief or perception about
ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwired
programs in your brain and the emotional
condition in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your voice possible no your body's
actually getting the taste of that
future event experiencing the future now
big explosion in the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lacking or lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
and that's 95 percent of who we are
right yes so then
the side effect of the beginning of this
process
is a lot of discomfort it is a lot of
discomfort because you're stepping
outside the known into the unknown and
now you can't predict it's scary no no
you'd rather hold on to your lack the
pain and suffering rather tell the story
of that at least it makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about that I don't
have any I'm not going to judge other
people who do I'm not going to say I can
I'm not worthy it's never going to work
all those things got to go I'm not going
to feel lack I'm not going to feel
unworthy I'm not going to feel
separation I'm not going to feel
resentment these are the things that are
keeping my reality the same now it's no
longer about abundance about who you
become
so the overcoming process becomes the
becoming process and so many people
come to this work they want abundance
they want healing they want a new
relationship they want a new career they
want the mystical but really they want
wholeness and and when healing they want
peace they want wholeness because they
feel on whole well well when you're in
lack or in separation you're not home
imagine feeling so much wholeness that's
impossible to want that's what our
that's what we're working on with people
then you can really enjoy a sunset then
you can really enjoy a meal and you can
really enjoy your friends then you can I
I
talk to people that are very abundant I
mean in the billions abundant and you
know
so many of them say we are in misery
because in our whole we're in agony
because they can enjoy life anymore
that's what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
I want whatever they want that's Freedom
right or people want abundance to
sponsoring thought is really they want
freedom right or whatever the sponsoring
thought would be rule number seven is be
positive the amount of emotion
that comes with the thought because
every time you have a thought you make a
chemical right if you have a good
thought and make you have a chemical
that makes you feel good you have an
arousing thought that causes you to feel
angry
short term that's okay but
the long-term effects of that keeps
knocking the brain and body out of
balance so
when we turn on that primitive nervous
system called the fight-or-flight
nervous system we're mobilizing enormous
amounts of energy in our body's
resources that we would typically use
for healing digestion reproduction
whatever assimilation we're robbing
those systems and we're saying there's a
threat there's a danger there's
something really really that needs all
of your attention in your outer
environment and that that arousal causes
us to feel fear or any derivative
derivative of it aggression or anger or
pain so
when we respond to the environment like
that our bodies knocked out of balance
because we're mobilizing all that energy
pupils dilate respiratory rate goes up
heart rate goes off up digestive juices
shut down blood is sent to the
extremities bodies ready to run fight or
hide
all organisms in nature can tolerate
that short term
if you turn on that stress response and
you can't turn it off now you're headed
for disease because no organism can live
an emergency mode without a moment for
for regeneration or growth and repair
all right so the arousal for some reason
feels good to human beings
and that arousal gives us a rush of
energy and then we need the bad news we
need the problems in our life we need
the poor relationship we need whatever
it is
to cause us to feel this kind of arousal
and because we're addicted to it will we
become addicted to the life we don't
even like so then that's the biggest aha
moment it's like you actually become
addicted to the life you don't want
right so then so take it a step further
then when you think about that life
you produce the same chemistry in your
brain and body in the same exact way as
if you were actually re-experiencing it
so now the thought
is turning on the stress response
and it's a scientific fact that the
long-term effects of the hormones stress
push the genetic buttons and create
disease well if you can turn on that
stress upon response just by thought
alone
then your thoughts could make you sick
so because you're knocking your brain
and body out of balance over and over
again and depleting your body's
resources that you could be used using
for healing and it just turns out the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you pay attention to the person or the
problem and that's our Vital life force
we're giving to that person or that
problem rule number eight is meditate we
have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoe strings on
the end of your DNA get longer that
means your biological age is changing so
we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
I mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now know that we can induce it so
then there's the evidence there then you
take
our community and you see people with
stage four cancer with Parkinson's
disease with myasthenia gravis with with
lupus with Ms with brain injuries with
rare genetic disorders with the vertigo
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions
come to a week-long event and then at
the end of that event they make
significant strides in getting beyond
the emotions of the past now think about
this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that Gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
Gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion well now they're dialing down
the gene for Ms and they're up
regulating the gene for health and
balance and so the person will you'll
say to them wears a disease well I'm not
the same person I'm not this and and the
side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now what they're talking about
is how amazing they feel because they're
refreshed they're they're they got a new
lease on life and so now we have
evidence in our research
and that silences the critic to show
that what's possible for people rule
number nine is make the right choices
the hardest part about all of this
is making a different choice and the
moment you decide to make a different
Choice get ready it's going to feel
uncomfortable right it's going to feel
unfamiliar your your body's all of a
sudden saying hey Louis uh why don't you
start thinking those same exact thoughts
do the same things make the same choices
that demonstrate the same behaviors have
the same experiences so you could feel
that feeling of lack complain again to
somebody call somebody up and say how
miserable your life is right and that's
that's the known right so the body is
always influencing the mind to return
back to the familiar territory the
default you're the default okay
all right so now the person says
okay what thoughts do I not want what
what would an abundant person think this
way the people in our work that have
created I had a guy come to our event I
I love this guy he healed himself he
tried to take his life three times when
he told me that when he came to our work
he didn't have two dollars to rub
together he's worth hundreds of millions
of dollars wow and he just keeps
giving it away wow
his his lesson his lesson was no it
wasn't the wealth was who he became so
it's the overcoming process
that is the becoming process who did he
become in that Journey exactly he had to
get beyond all of those thoughts of his
past all the mistakes he made all the
things he did wrong all the money he
owed there all of that that was like he
just had to no longer be that person any
longer but he did say
how would a wealthy person live and and
and when he created his wealth what do
you think the first thing he did started
giving giving it away why because an
abundant person doesn't have any lack
and he knows how to create more of it in
this he's in the experiment well what
would happen if I keep giving it away he
keeps getting more that's a good
experiment to have because that he is
actually living in that abundant State
he also had tremendous healings taking
place because when you heal your heart
heal your mind I mean it's just the way
it is we saw it so many times right so
he healed his heart he's got an upgrade
he got an upgrade I know number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is believe the Journey Back To
Source the journey back to Oneness the
Journey Back everybody gets to you can
be anybody you want to be in three
dimensions you can be any character you
want to be in the virtual reality
experiences the simulation that we're
experiencing
but if you're living by the same
emotions every day
or you can't get out of bed because you
can predict the feeling of everything
that's going to happen in your life then
nothing's going to change until you
change and the discovery of okay
most people have to hit their lowest
point in their life where that nothing's
making that feeling go away to finally
look at how they think look at how they
act look at how they feel my message is
why wait for that like and so what we're
discovering is in seven days in seven
days the science that we have
is so compelling to show that in seven
days there will be a host of biological
changes that take place in a person's
body to actually look like they're
living in a new environment living in a
whole new life
so then
getting over yourself to answer your
question is the difficulty that's why
people will say uh it's too hard for me
but what they're really saying is I
don't believe in that I don't really
don't believe in it because if you
believe in it
you got to show up and if you don't
believe in it then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself that means you don't believe in
possibility if you don't believe in
possibility that means you can't believe
in yourself
chronic diseases require a lifestyle
change and and change is an interesting
concept so the hardest part about change
is not making the same Choice as you did
the day before and the moment you decide
to make a different Choice get ready
because you're going to feel
uncomfortable it's going to feel
unfamiliar there's going to be some
uncertainty you're not going to be in
the known you're stepping out into the
unknown you're doing something
differently in the body which has been
conditioned to be the mind the servant
is now the master
so the body loves The Familiar known it
loves the same suffering it loves the
same pain and loves the same
unworthiness it's been conditioned that
way for years on end it really is
running the show so the moment you step
out into the unknown the body goes away
to Second I'd rather feel guilty than
this feeling of the unknown because I
can't predict my future so the body
starts influencing the mind and we start
to hear this chatter in our head that
says Rock and start tomorrow you know
tomorrow's a better day you really don't
feel like it today why don't you just
have one piece of cake you're a loser
it's your parents fault it's your ex's
fault it's your culture's fault whatever
it is and if we accept believe and
surrender to that thought as if it's the
truth that's an old circuit in the brain
that thought will lead to the same
Choice which will lead to the same
behavior which will create the same
experience but produce the same feeling
or emotion the person says well this
feels right to me no no no no that feels
familiar crossing the river of change
going from the old self to the new self
there is a neurological a biological or
hormonal genetic death of the old self
there's pruning going on there's there's
inhibition going on where we're no
longer releasing the same stress
hormones that give us the arousal and so
if there's three types of stress
physical chemical and emotional physical
stress being trauma injuries accidents
Falls chemical stress you know viruses
bacteria pesticides pollutants toxins
hangovers whatever emotional stress
that's the big one that's a family
tragedies second mortgages single
parenting 401ks whatever it is it tends
to be then that the difficult one to
manage really is our emotional stress so
if you can help people to get more
physically balanced more chemically
balanced and to become more emotionally
balanced than the effects of their
personal change will be expedited yeah
and there'll be a longer duration so the
person sees you for six months they
start a great program they start making
the right choices and they start feeling
better and then once they make the wrong
choice then it's a downward spiral back
to the old unconscious habits and
emotional conditions they feel unworthy
again and they return back to your
clinic or they return back to your
consultation and they come back with the
same exact conditions and The Simple
Solution is yeah because you return back
to the same personality and you're
feeling the same emotions and your
body's back to believing it's in the
same environmental condition so if your
personality
creates your personal reality and I
believe that and your personality is
made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life not
your ex not your parents not your boss
you create your life so it makes sense
then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality you'd have to change
your personality in other words if you
want to change your life you have to
change and nothing changes in your life
until you change so then this first step
and change then
95 of who we are as a set of unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions then the
first step is to become conscious of
your unconscious thoughts become so
aware of how you behave do you complain
do you blame do you make excuses you
judge do you are you aggressive and then
look at the emotions what is this
emotion I'm feeling wow this is guilt
this is sadness this is victimization
this is unhappiness name it so now
you're so conscious of it that you don't
go unconscious and return back to the
same self and how many times
do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being if you take a
thought and a feeling a thought and a
feeling of thought and a feeling of
thought a feeling it's called an
attitude this is a good thoughts with a
series of Good Feelings you say I have a
good attitude today you have a series of
negative thoughts that are connected to
a series of negative feelings you say
have a bad attitude today so attitudes
are just shortened states of being good
attitude in the morning bad attitude in
the afternoon if you take an attitude
and attitude imagine you keep those up
any string attitudes together you create
what's called a belief and a belief is
just an extended state of being so if
you keep thinking the same thought you
keep hardwiring in the brain you keep
feeling the same feeling you keep
conditioning in your body the redundancy
of that cycle over and over again
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of that belief and all
beliefs
our subconscious states of being okay
take a belief a belief a belief and you
string them together you're from what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are right and
people are always feeling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this okay so
how do we change a belief or perception
about ourself for our lives okay we've
studied this
okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story you
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took you
got the story in the half okay okay you
got to start telling the new story of
the future right you got to believe in
that future more than you have to
believe in the past so how do you do
that you only believe in the past when
you feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
of the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
condition in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your voice possible no your body's
actually getting the taste of that
future event experiencing the future now
exactly big explosion on the quantum
field big explosion so the side effect
of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack or lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
that's how powerful we are you could
actually like the story We Tell
ourselves
is how we perceive the world
and so then then when we create the
difficulties in our life it reaffirms
the belief that life is hard that it's
really someone out there that's doing it
to us that it's a circumstance in the
past that created this okay let's take
away the person that did it let's shoot
him to the Moon Let's uh let's erase
your past now what are you going to do
now I am you still you still got to do
something right you're still alive and
I say we already know how to do this we
already know how to do this we're wired
to be creators we're wired to do this
the thing that stops us for the most
part in doing it is really the hormones
of stress because living in stress
constantly is living in survival and
living in survivals living in emergency
in an emergency it's not a time to
create an emergency it's not a time to
open your heart it's not a time to learn
it's not even a time to sit still
so most people then that are living in
stress and living in survival they can't
believe in a future yet because it's not
a time to create so getting people to
that point
where they make up their mind and they
make up their mind enough to begin to
think there's got to be a better way
there's got to be something else
that Awakening process typically happens
when people reach their lowest
denominator
they hit rock bottom because then they
can see themselves Through The Eyes of
somebody else you're you feel so altered
you're not returning any texts you feel
so altered you want to go to dinner with
your buddies you feel so altered you
know you don't want to watch your
favorite TV show you're just you're just
disconnected and that's when you start
observing yourself
but my message is why wait for that I
mean you can learn and change and pain
and suffering or you can learn and
change and joy and inspiration if you're
waking up every morning being defined by
a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past and you get up and
you're inspired from an elevated self
now instead of a limited self you could
observe the old self from an elevated
State instead of that diminished State
and people are doing that so they are
aware
of those thoughts and yes it takes uh
effort and if it was easy everybody
would be doing it but just because you
have a thought doesn't necessarily mean
it's true and when you start looking and
observing those thoughts
um I think you are like Gandalf because
Gandalf also said you know you may not
pass you know when he meant like that's
kind of severity when it comes to how we
we make up our mind about things that's
the kind of energy or intention that
begins to create the biggest volume of
change in our life and I've interviewed
thousands of people in our work that
have
healed from really serious health
conditions and I would say about 90 of
them when I asked them so what happened
the first thing they say all the time is
I just made up my mind I just made up my
mind I was going to do this and they
made a decision
with such firm intention that the
amplitude of that decision carried a
level of energy that was greater than
the hardwired programs in their brain
and the emotional conditioning in their
body and the choice that they made
caused their body to respond to a new
mind in fact the choice they made became
a moment that they would never forget it
was an event and the stronger the
emotion they felt the more they paid
attention to the choice and in a sense
they were remembering their future and
the body emotionally was getting a
sampling a taste of the future and they
are lying to that future and
that's when the body's healing began
that's when the miracle started right in
that moment that's how powerful we
really are now what if you did that
every day what if you made up your mind
every single day you weren't going to
get up from your meditation until you
were that person you wanted to be game
on now because you'd have to do battle
with all the things that are not
consistent with it and that's exactly
how our brain works so then if you want
to be wealthy you can't feel lack
you want to be a master you can't judge
your co-worker you want to be like
somebody great in history then you
better execute peace in every area of
your life that's that's the law so
you take the prayer out on the road now
you take the prayer you're the living
example of the prayer that's where
that's where it matters the most and
that's when people start getting
suspicious and say shun man you change
your medication I mean you're looking
way too happy all of a sudden well
you're not relying on anything outside
of you to bring your joy you're you're
you're overcoming yourself every day and
people say to me well why do you do your
meditations in the morning I always say
easy because if I can overcome myself at
the beginning of the day the rest of the
day is easy right because that's the
biggest that's the biggest Master right
is the self the moment you lose the
feeling of your future you start looking
for it
because you feel separate from it but if
you feel it why would you look for it
because you feel like it already
happened that's when the magic happens
boom that's an epiphany that's it like
whoa yeah when you look for it feeling
it you're separate from it yeah so when
people start learning how to we have we
have documentation yeah people in this
work can sustain hard coherence for 45
minutes to an hour they know that they
know how to do it it's so important for
people to remember that they're the
creators of their lives instead of the
victim of their life the victim is
saying I'm feeling this way because that
person that circumstance or I don't have
any money is causing me to feel this way
that's my relationship with money what
that really means is I'm using my lack
to reaffirm my dependency my addiction
my conditioning that's my relationship
with money is that I put my attention on
money because I don't have it the
relationship with money is of course
built on lack and so when they don't
have it they feel bad what they're
really saying is my outer environment my
reality is actually controlling the way
I feel the way I think so Lewis why are
you in a good mood today things are
going good why in a bad mood things are
going bad today so this unconscious
program victimization is saying that
we're allowing our environment to
influence the way we feel and the way we
think isn't that isn't that good
victimization is and the stronger the
emotion we have to our lack the more we
put our attention on the fact that we
don't have it so then the person has
forgotten that they're creating reality
because what they're creating is lack
let's create from the field instead of
from matter it's going to coherent heart
get a coherent brain relax in the heart
and energy moves right in the brain
we've measure this thousand times and
all of a sudden the person moves into
these beautiful elegant brainwave states
where they're super creative right the
longer you're conscious of that energy
the more you draw that future to you so
then what does the synchronicity mean it
means whatever you're doing inside of
you is producing that effect outside of
you pay attention to what you did again
so generate a little bit more abundance
just do it for an experiment now when
the synchronicity happens do you think
you feel suffering or do you think you
feel a little excitement you feel
inspired right so then that
synchronicity is saying use this energy
use this feeling it should be easier for
you to feel this now and go back and do
it again keep the experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then we generate abundance that's
that's how we do it and the relationship
doesn't just happen by accident we
generated we generate abundance right so
then if you have an hour meditation
where you're tuning into your abundant
future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change your defaulted and
you're back to the old energy and if you
say it's that person or that
circumstance or that bank account I'm
going to say you're back to the
unconscious program being a victim right
and so then so then
so then let's go a step further
if your personality creates your
personal reality and it does and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life
nothing big there which means if you
want to change your personal reality
you're going to have to change your
personality right nothing changes in
your life until you change be the
example I mean show the world what
greatness looks like show the world what
love looks like show the world with
patience looks like show the world that
leadership looks like show the world so
that you can give people permission to
say wow
something's different about you like
what is it I want something what is that
don't go around telling people you need
the sure you need to forgive your father
you need to shorten your emotional
response don't do that show the world
what it looks like so they say what is
it what is it about you that's different
or the the you show up and you're no
longer matching the memory they have of
you like
who is this person yeah what happened to
you that's so important for people
because that means you're out of face
right so the world needs this is not a
time to to go to the Himalayas we need
you here we need you here yes we need
you to be the example you gotta this is
a time to stand up for the truth right
and we gotta we gotta show the world
what it looks like and and every single
person creates that emerging
Consciousness every bird that's in that
pattern every fish that's in that school
that are moving is one mind and one
heart there is no leader everybody's
leading this is a time where everybody's
gotta lead in this community absolutely
it's the Future No No health care plan
no religion excuse me
um
no government really is going to take
care of people the way they should be
taken care of right now and I don't mean
that in a in a secular way I'm sure
there's religions that really take care
of people but what I'm saying is we we
need to create a collective
Consciousness and Collective networks of
observers determine reality there's a
biology to personal change and
transformation so we have this emerging
youth that that has to resolve the
problems that have been created by this
past generation from a greater level of
Consciousness and that means when
everybody else is angry everybody else
is frustrated you're going to have to
show compassion
when everybody else is fearful and
worried you're gonna have to show
courage but everybody else is racing and
rushing and competing to succeed and
climbing over each other to get to the
top you're gonna have to learn how to be
in the present moment and draw to you
and I think if you do that in the
beginning
it feels unnatural because everybody
else is doing something else
but how do we become Supernatural unless
we start doing the things that feel
unnatural so anger is not going to
resolve it that's actually what's
created Prejudice is not going to
resolve it that's what's created it
greed is not going to resolve it that's
what is actually actually has created it
and so
we're in a time right now right before
our eyes we're watching the world in
many ways that experience such extreme
polarity
that the wobbling of polarity is
breaking the system right and it's
creating chaos is disorder chaos is the
no longer the known as we're in a big
unknown right now
so when there's brain and heart
coherence God we have such incredible
data they could take if I trained you on
how to do that you could be running
around doing a thousand different things
and I could say Emilio sit down you got
15 minutes uh to synchronize your heart
to your brain we do this all the time
and whether the young guys running
around chasing this one-year-old
two-year-old kid one of my staff is
running around doing a thousand
different things sit down they sit down
and all of a sudden music starts and you
see them start moving in and all of a
sudden you see this beautiful low
frequency take place in the heart and
once we see that it starts to build you
see the parasympathetic nervous system
go up which means either relaxing and
then the virusympathetic nervous system
goes down and the sympathetic nervous
system goes up
and all of a sudden the brain moves into
those gamma patterns and that person
the heart is informing the brain the
heart is telling the brain it's safe to
create the heart is giving the brain
information we actually see this now the
brain the heart has Intelligence brain
thinks but the heart knows
so all of a sudden the heart says Emilio
it's it's time to create you're out of
survival and you get these incredible
ideas you get the mystical moment you
get the understanding you get the
download you get whatever that is people
can do that now on command now why is
that important
because you know most people are
stressed
in survival and unconscious in a program
and racing and rushing to try to make
that feeling of emptiness or pain go
away and there's and they're lost in the
illusion of Separation thinking they
need the outer environment to do it
chaos is happening you got to be the eye
of a storm you got to be relaxed and out
of survival and awake and heart and
brain coherence means relaxed and awake
so then we take our youth and we're
investing in our youth right now because
they're going to be the leaders of our
future
we want to teach them what leadership
truly is from the heart we want to teach
them how to make changes that are
permanent we want them to consider the
whole we want them to come up with ideas
that we will be interested in supporting
and backing that will create that kind
of cultural change that takes place and
most importantly
that they get along with one another I
mean why can't we just get along with
each other take away all the
all the governments take away all all
the different cultures and you see
people in life you see modern events a
thousand people 2 000 people all Races
all all cultures we all get along
everybody loves everybody I mean that's
that's who we innately are never try to
reason with your children they're
emotional
because no new information can enter the
nervous system that isn't equal to the
emotion they're experiencing
do you want to be reasoned with when
you're emotional do you want to be left
alone
you want a few minutes yes now if
there's an injury if there's danger of
course you have to step in if there's
chemical needs of course you have to you
know take care of that but for the most
part with my children I allowed them
to have their moment
but whatever whenever they had their
moment I would stop
whatever I was doing and I would turn
and look at them
and I would watch them I wanted them to
know that I was observing them never
said anything to them unless they asked
and when the emotions wore off I would
say to them
at the end of the day I'd get in bed
with them and I'd say
for me today
and I would share with them what I was
working on as if they were my best
friend or an adult I didn't hold back at
all with them
and I would do that
to create the space of safety where they
could start expressing
what they knew that I observed about
them
in the most objective way
self-reflective way
and then they would say oh yeah you know
I lost my temper with Paris you know her
friend and I said I know I saw you
this is right before they go to bed
what's their brain waves at this point
very suggestible
they're already dipping into Theta
they're an alpha they're in the love
stories because it helps them to imagine
and then I would say to them the same
thing every time you know
I really don't care what happened
what I care about is if you had another
opportunity in the same situation
how you would do it differently I just
want to know how we could evolve your
experience
and then of course they would give me
answers that were always Limited
you know especially my boys but you know
and I say yeah well if you do that you
know more than likely this is going to
happen did you think of that
no and then we go back and forth until
we had a very clear understanding of
what would be the higher road to take
the next time
and then I would say to them no
just so I'm sure that I understand this
can you repeat it back to me like that
happened again what would you do
and then they would go and say it and
they'd fall off a little bit and I'd
bring them back and I'd review it with
them until the point where they could
explain it exactly what they would do
are you with me what did they just do
they mentally rehearsed it
yes or no
and they're installing the circuitry
they're priming their brain for the
experience I'm giving them tools
neurologically
are you with me still and I say to them
then if you did that then that more than
likely would create this experience and
how would you feel
and I would let them just contact that
feeling just for a minute and all I
wanted to do was combine an intention
and an emotion a new emotion you with me
then I'd get him in bed tuck him in and
I would tell him a story of these kids
that lived in a mystical land with
castles and dragons and princesses and
and then I would tell them the story of
these kids and then I would bring in
their story
into
the allegory because there's a story
allegory is a great way to associate
with characters
and then I would tell them the lessons
that they learned while I repeated it
back to them in a very creative story
and so many times they look at me just
before they fall asleep and they'd say
was that me
let's say I don't know was it
the next day I'd get them up of course
I'm up you know before the sun come on
come on get up we got things to do come
on I connect with them I always connect
with them and let them know that they're
important and that they matter and that
they love them and I would tell them how
the day was going to go the main things
that I'm going to remind you just so you
have some structure and then there's
going to be time to play but we have to
get these things done I give I just help
them understand that there was some
ritual involved in this some boundaries
some intention
and then when we're at breakfast I'd say
what was it
that you would do if you had that same
situation with Paris again tell me
and then I would have them rehearse it
again and I would do it to the point
that they would say
well they wouldn't say that they'd say
just
want this thing to happen so you would
leave because you can just leave me
alone just I just can't wait for it to
happen so I can get on with my life if
you don't know
that that's possible right then it
doesn't exist for you right like if
you're if you're unconscious to the fact
that you could heal yourself you'll make
the same choices you always do so so I'm
challenged in my own way at a different
level to to to do my best to do the
right make the right choices all the
time and sometimes those choices
um I can't I can't rely on anybody else
but me to make those choices because
nobody else knows what it's like to be
me then me even my closest friends think
they know me but they but when it comes
down to making the choice it's a lonely
moment right because I'm doing my best
to try to preserve this work and to
inspire people to apply it in their
lives as many ways as I can so so a lot
of times I get discouraged like oh my
God like another challenge another
challenge but you know I think you know
when I'm truly
in the right Zone I I think the only way
that we actually can grow in our lives
is to be challenged right so and I think
that I mean the greater the greater we
evolve or the greater we become I think
the greater the challenges you know and
so so I'm I have my own set of
challenges that I have to really Retreat
from my life
I've spent a lot of time alone and I
really remember that vision and I have
to and I have this I have to get beyond
all those other things that say well my
God this is this might be a good time
for you to quit this is a good time for
you as well this is getting pretty
intense I consider myself a pretty
open-minded person I mean I have a
pretty good meter too like I I
have a truth to me or that like I just
I'm a I'm a practical person yeah I want
to talk about Quantum superimposition if
it doesn't change my life in any way I
want to know how it's going to affect my
life I'm a pragmatist so I consider
myself a pretty open-minded person but I
have you know I'm skeptical about things
because I want to challenge them
in a way that I think it really helps
people right so
when I saw you know some of the dramatic
changes take place
I was I I I I I never thought in my
lifetime
that I would be witnessing what I'm in
what I witnessed and every single
week-long event that we've done and
we've done 30 of them now
and it's never been a disappointment
there's just a transformative thing that
takes place that is way bigger than me
so when you see a person with a stroke
who's blind in the quarter of their
Vision or has paralysis and can't move
an arm
and you see that Vision completely
restored and then you see the scan that
shows there's no longer any blemish or
damage to the visual field
you just you can't go back
to business as usual you can't go back
to being the same person you once you
know
you can't not know and and and it's so
beautiful because
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
is noticing and paying attention
so when you see a person who has a
transformation and you see the science
that says in a week-long event
there'll be over 600 metabolic changes
in 75 percent of the audience for the
better in a one-week event
when you when you know that
you're now you're aware of another
possibility that may not be the
possibility that we think is free will
to choose from gnomes this is now you're
stepping outside
and when a person shows up and believes
in themselves and does the work
they're believing in possibility you
cannot believe in possibility
and and and believe in yourself not
believe in yourself you got to believe
in yourself and believe in possibility
you got to believe in possibility you
got to believe in yourself
so
for me personally I I it's way bigger
than me I'm very humbled on a regular
basis every time I get another
testimonial
uh I say this person is speaking the
truth
and and it's it's a footprint
for somebody else to step into and
I think the world needs that more than
ever so for me
um
my greatest passion my greatest joy I
think there's some there's something in
US Glenn that's so empathetic uh now
we're we have universities that are
studying we're studying
people that can be healed remotely you
don't even need to be in their presence
if you understand the science of quantum
physics and you understand how to do it
you can hit a Target
and heal another person at a distance
and there it is and there it's gone
now when you see that occur
there's some kind of empathy I I drop in
on the calls of these people that show
up every single day of their life to
heal another person and they do at least
three or four a day
and these people they're not doing it
because they want to be a Healer
they're doing it because well how they
feel when they see a mother who's
comes on the zoom call and says my
daughter was you know a handicapped from
birth she had a traumatic birth she's
listless unresponsive never looked at
her brothers and all of a sudden this
kid is smiling at her brothers and
trying to talk and you watch the
people on the zoom call that are the
healers you see everywhere all in tears
there's this empathy that takes place
where we're contributing as a species to
one another that we were part of
somebody's transformation we gave in
some way another one of us is better in
this kind of feeling of empathy this
feeling of connection is so profound
that goes against all those survival and
stress emotions that create Division and
polarity and separation and and distrust
and and so
that's when Community starts coming
together that's when we start to
collaborate cooperate and it and it's
got to be from the heart so
I'm super hopeful about
um well what what we're doing when
you're at a greater level of awareness
everything seems to be more connected
that's what the quantum is so you're
playing at that level the
synchronicities the serendipities the
coincidences are actually informing you
that you actually are creating your life
and that's the difference between being
the victim of your life and being the
creator of your life because when the
environment is controlling the way we
feel and the way we think some person
some circumstance some condition what
does that really mean that means that
person or circumstance is actually
causing me to think and feel a certain
way and and I I don't think I have any
control of it then I must be victim to
that circumstance right and that's a
program right yeah so so I I realized in
my own Journey also that
if I don't change my response
to things in my life I'll never change
so so it's not even it's not that you
responded the question really is how
long right so when you become aware that
your environment is controlling how you
think and feel and your response changes
watch out because that now you no longer
belong to the Past you actually belong
to the Future so get a coherent heart we
know how to do that really well gotta go
here and brain we can do that really
well have people take all of their
attention on off the material world of
everything known go from a convergent
Focus to a diversion Focus we've got the
data to prove that if you keep putting
your attention on nothing on Space
somehow the brain gets highly organized
so now brain coherence heart coherence
you synchronize your energy to whatever
it is you want and you got to sustain
that state you can't we've had people
that have healed themselves from
Parkinson's disease from cancers
from ALS literally remission of the
condition and then have bad news
and in one hour driving to the hospital
all of their symptoms came back after
being completely healed for two years
That's How Strong those emotions are
right so so so in your circumstance
right
I want people
I want people to have those moments
where they have to literally choose
because I think
when it's the hardest it matters the
most that's what I think so so all those
things where you're agitated with the
person having their moment you know that
could be you having your moment right
and you would want someone like that
person doesn't want to do that they're
just having their thing can I teach my
body emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can feel
it because it hasn't happened yet that's
the conditioning that's the hypnosis
so then when you teach Purple People how
to create hard coherence and
self-regulate and it makes sense then
with a coherent brain they can hold the
image of their future they can actually
then rehearse who they're going to be
they can bring up the emotions of their
future now here's the cool part awesome
if they can feel their gratitude before
their healing their Healing Begins if
they feel their abundance or their
worthiness
before they have their wealth it will
start generating abundance if they start
being in love with themselves and being
in love with life they'll create an
equal that's the law
if they're in awe of life or an awe of
the moment they're going to have a
mystical experience if they're empowered
they're going to start stepping towards
their success success so then when we
wait for the outer World to Change our
internal State that's a conditioning
process because some people will live in
lack and separation their entire life
because they're not creating anything
when this happens then I'll feel happy
that's the illusion of three-dimensional
reality that's cause and effect but
feeling the emotion ahead of the
experience is causing an effect so the
heart when it's coherent tends to
produce
an external magnetic field that's up to
three meters wide now you've got a Wi-Fi
signal now when you have a coherent
brain the brain could actually lay the
information
on that signal and the thought of your
wealth or your health can be carried on
the frequency of that heart emotion
emotions are the end product of an
experience right
epigenetics says it's the environment
that signals the gene if the environment
signals the Gene and the end product of
an experience in the environment is an
emotion a person's signaling genes ahead
of the environment and now they're
biologically
believing behaving and actually becoming
that person so if the person sustains
that state and we look at novice
meditators that come for a week
ninety percent of them and and the
metabolites not just a few the majority
of the metabolites and novice meditators
suggest that their body's in a different
life don't expect
anything in your life to change if your
environment
is controlling your feelings and
thoughts and if your environment is
controlling how you feel and think and I
say to you Aubry why are you so upset
today oh well this person is upsetting
me what you're really saying is that
person
is controlling your feelings and your
thoughts and that means you're a victim
to your environments well to turn that
around and you start realizing your
feelings and thoughts create your
environment
and you start seeing the effects of you
at cause
you're going to react less the people in
your life because you're going to
understand that you'll be back to the
victim Consciousness and and when you
start seeing that you're creating
outcomes in your life you're going to
believe more that you're the creator of
your life unless the victim of your life
and I say the more you practice it
the better you get at it believe in the
thought I can't meditate or I don't have
enough time or I'm a really important
person or I got too many too many emails
to answer it's garbage day or it's my
mother's fault it's my ex's fault I want
to complain I want to blame I want to
make excuses I want to lay down my
bladder is full I like this what am I
doing wrong they're agitated and patient
that's
that's the personality that has been
hardwired
and conditioned emotionally into the
past that's resisting the unknown it
would rather cling to suffering than
take a chance in possibilities so our
events we say okay here's the knowledge
and I can say now with
a great degree of certainty more than
ever that if you actually do this and
you stretch yourself a little bit
further
than where you would normally go at home
your brain will change and if you teach
people how to do this
over and over again and no different
than training an animal the body is the
animal are you training the body that
you're in charge is that what you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind yes and when you do
that those victories add up and all of a
sudden there's a liberation of energy
there goes the guilt there goes the pain
there goes the whatever it doesn't
matter if it's Health it doesn't matter
if it's wealth or success it doesn't
matter if it's a loving relationship a
change in a career or mystical
experience whatever it is the person all
of a sudden starts to relax into the
present moment the greatest challenge uh
when we have uh strong emotions that are
stored in the brain and body is it's
very difficult
uh to think greater than how we feel
that I think that is the challenge
and uh feelings are a record of the past
so so
the person if they can't think greater
than how they feel then they can't see a
possible future
because they're looking at that future
through the lens of their past biology
and so
the best thing for a person to do if
they're truly truly committed to change
is to really understand what change
means and really understand that there's
a biology and a very specific
explanation of what change is okay so
the person says I didn't create this
reality okay okay you didn't create that
reality I didn't ask for the life that
I'm living okay you didn't ask for the
life that you're living okay
um
I didn't pick these parents somehow I
was born into this family okay great
so now what
I mean now what are I mean like if our
excuse to change is really it's that
person or that circumstance or that past
that's really making me feel that's why
you can do that for a while
but if you start reading and learning
and filling your brain with knowledge
and making new Connections in your brain
you got more raw materials to start
thinking about new possibilities now
that's what information does information
every time you learn something new
you're making thousands of synaptic
Connections in your brain repeat it
review it think about it talk about it
share it and those circuits begin to
create long-term connections called
Memories and now you're adding more
three-dimensional stitches into the
tapestry of your gray matter and and
you're building information to see that
there are other ways to live now
pick up a book on someone who's had
trauma and they turn that trauma around
and they live their life in joy and then
and they see it differently and you're
picking up and relating with the story
and at the same time you're realizing
you're identifying with this character
and if they can do it you can do it too
all right so now the possibility exists
okay
now the person really who truly wants to
be happy says I can't I can't live in my
past any longer okay I understand that I
know it's hard and I'm gonna I'm gonna
default back to my old personality maybe
10 times or 20 times or a hundred times
in one day
that's okay because if I'm alive
tomorrow I'm gonna try and do it better
the next day I'm not gonna think act and
feel this way
so how many times do we have to forget
until we really stop forgetting and
start remembering
how many times do we go unconscious in
our waking day that we have to stop
going unconscious and stay conscious
so the person who no longer wants to be
and I hate to use this word victimized
by their life but
excusing themselves from the possibility
that there could be an alternative way
to live a new life to live in the person
who excuses themselves that way is
because they can't imagine a new life
greater than how they typically feel and
of course it takes trauma or disease or
diagnosis or loss or betrayal
for the person to be so knocked out of
balance that they finally say I have to
change
and they can tell you exactly where they
were the time of day it was who they
were with when they made up their mind
to change this happens thousands of
times in our research the person says
I'm making up my mind in this moment and
they make a decision with such firm
intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy that causes
their body to respond to their mind
that the choice that they're making in
that moment in time is a moment in time
they will never forget
in other words the stronger the emotion
they felt when they made that choice
independent of what was going on in
their environment and their life the
more they'll remember the choice they're
making that's what emotions do and that
gives the body a sampling or a taste of
the future they're changing their state
of being in one instant everybody has
done this
at some point in their life right where
they have to catch the thought
they have to catch their how they speak
the ACT they have to notice oh this is
that weird feeling again I'm not going
to just stay in this feeling can I
change it right so then if you remind
yourself every single day of who you no
longer want to be before you start your
day become conscious of your unconscious
self so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious in your waking day the
next fundamental question is if your
personality creates your personal
reality
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and with attention with
presence and intention energy
begin to Fire and wire that thought if
you can fire and wire that thought you
start installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain keep doing it and
start acting acting like a software
program it becomes more automatic that's
the new voice in your head that says you
can it's possible or whatever and then
how are you going to behave in the zoom
meeting how are you going to behave with
your children how are you going to
behave with your ex how are you going to
be today when you open your eyes now
here's the cool part and you know this
the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing who you're going to
be planning your actions in the day
mental rehearsal
shows that you could actually install
the neurological Hardware in your brain
to look like you already did it or it
already happened now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it now
becomes a map to the Future okay we've
all rehearsed something in our life and
our minds over and over again keep doing
it keep rehearsing it keep reviewing it
and it'll start to become more automatic
and you could actually program a person
then to behave as a happy person no
magic there you install the circuits now
here's the hardest part
can you teach your body emotionally
what that future would feel like before
it happens in other words don't wait for
your healing to feel gratitude don't
wait for your new relationship to feel
love don't wait for the mystical moment
to feel awe that's kind of the old model
of reality of cause and effect let's
wait for something out there to happen
to take away this emptiness this guilt
this lack the suffering whatever what if
I could condition my body emotionally
into the future so then we started
studying not only brain coherence but we
started studying heart coherence could a
person trade resentment and watch their
heart beat in a really irregular fashion
to a more coherent fashion where when
they're feeling gratitude when they're
feeling inspiration when they're feeling
love could they practice that enough
times so much so
that they can condition their body into
the emotion of the future now here's the
cool part about that
our research shows you could absolutely
do that and do it so well that you feel
like the future that you're in wanting
to experience has already happened and
when it feels like it's already happened
you feel less separate from it which
means you're no longer looking for it
why would you look for it if you feel
like it's already happened now
to become familiar with the old self and
then fire and wire and condition the
body emotionally and chemically and
become familiar with the new self if
you're truly in the experiment of life
and I truly change my personality
there should be some evidence in my
world that there's been some change
either in my body and in my life in some
way and literally
their biology changes their their their
immune system changes they're we've
we've isolated thousands of metabolites
that show that that there's a
flourishing going on in the body the
body's responding it's believing
emotionally that it's living in a
different environment that's that's the
key
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Consciousness is
creating your reality if you put a
picture of fear into your reality then
your biology Behavior will manifest
things to be afraid of because this is a
short statement but to me it's the most
powerful one